and so it it makes us narcissistic
almost because we think the whole world
revolves around us
but the same thing of what empowers you
also makes you blind because even though
you think you're being empowered but
then when you're not getting wiped by
the man that you want and he goes into
the real wild world and you realize I'm
actually very regular degular I'm
nothing special
okay
but what class of women are you talking
about like how intellectual are they
where do they come from what are women
or you think all women think like this
most women yeah
you get the dating app data which allows
women to be very honest and women only
swipe right five percent of the time
they're not ugly in pictures though no
women find 80 no no women find 80 of men
unattractive not uh okay like
unattractive but what about in person no
just anywhere anywhere yeah eighty
percent of men they find unattractive
but because I've spoken to them or
because on face value they like there's
something chemically that they're like
because they've had better sexually and
they're just their standards are skewed
so yeah so a lot of a lot of times I'll
hear girls say things like oh he's
medium ugly and I'm like no sis that's
your level
but but you know that term you've heard
it right oh you've never heard Medium
you're not on social media right
Snapchat
there's only 20 of men are actually
having sex 20 yeah so one out of one out
of three men either virgins or haven't
had sex in the past year
and that's the trend so that's the trend
that's going going on the last like 50
years where it's like 50s yes slowly
it's a bigger and bigger percentage of
men aren't having sex so but if most
women are having sex that means they're
having sex with the same guys
that's like why do you think women say
things like men are trash all men cheat
no
but it's here it's serious because
everything funny has a little bit of
Truth in it right but it's because we're
dating the same ones okay
um so for the past 50 years only 20 men
have been having sex
is that right look at that rough yeah
yeah so prior to that
woman we're having sex because women
were less free in a way yeah because
because we had more we we had we had to
vet men more because we could possibly
get pregnant because birth control is a
Fail-Safe right if you get if you get an
IUD you have like a 99 chance of not
getting pregnant okay so that's a
Fail-Safe and if that doesn't work you
can get an abortion
um but and so they we had to prioritize
a man that was gonna stick around okay
and typically like we got married
younger and the men around us vetted the
men around us like our fathers would vet
guys before we would go on dates with
them and stuff and like women we're kind
of dumb like a guy can sweet talk us and
like yeah like we're not you know
because you know it's true right and so
but men vet men better because they can
tell you when someone's like talking
[__] to you because if a guy's smooth he
had to practice to get there the boy the
guys aren't just born smooth
I mean sometimes they don't want to hear
it like I have female friends that will
ask me stuff
um about the way guys are acting and you
tell them and they they're still okay
with what's happening because they'll
still like
go along with the game that he's playing
Because deep you probably know it's a
game but you're enjoying it and you want
you
I think I think they just see
um
I think they just see potential they go
the game's happening hopefully he's
gonna change
um I want him to change and
he'll change for me because he's with me
he's hit and this is what I want so it's
the delusion in them selfish in some
regards but it is what it is women their
attraction is is
they take their ideas from other women
they want the guy that they're they're
going after to be validated by other
women and that's what part yes and she
realizes he's the alpha within this
group and where it changes revolutionary
previously it might have been
um say being able to be a fighter being
able to protect now it's it's about
wealth high value status within your
Echo Chambers or the values you respect
yeah you need other women importantly
women that you respect for example the
the commodity in the sexual Marketplace
as women is her looks other women that
you recognize as pretty to also have a
vested interest in this guy
and that's that's how random in the game
why do you think
um why are women grossed out at dirty
jokes but the same women do those things
in the bedroom
because they don't because they don't
want to seem like
they do that they don't it's like the
stigma that they have oh I don't want to
seem like a like a [__] but in the dark
they like slap me out let's let's let me
know like it's just it's just that like
image that they want to keep and so it's
it's crazy as like if you do it just own
up to it and just
um if they did that a lot of men value
Purity yeah
men would be attractive if she was to
say like yeah I like bakaki on my face I
think it's the same reason like body
count so yeah are you talking about like
with uh with friends or like if a dude
said that dirty joke to them they were
like oh no I don't do that yeah I don't
know it's just a question
yeah I think with friends they they
don't seem with friends they
trust me both with men's and friends
they hide it and they don't like tell it
I think with men they do it more
it gets to a point with friends like
maybe a friend will say and I've had
this in my friend group they'll say
something like they did to with their
dude and they'll be like oh she's she's
crazy too she's a freak in the bedroom
too I can say what I what I did as well
and then there'll be like a conversation
of what they did and it's like an
openness once they find out that one
girl is just as crazy yeah they'll be
like okay I can find comfort in this
group now but with dudes I don't know I
don't think open up yeah so I have a
question for the guys so you you said
that body count doesn't matter so much
to you no no in the context of what we
are yeah so so question how many bodies
is Too Many Bodies how many bodies is
Too Many Bodies
damn I have to give a Hardline
responsibility you could say plus or
minus like you know roughly
I think
the age I'm at now
mid to late 20s
I think anything in the in London
because everyone will lie about the body
count I know where the people are on in
school below 10 is good 10 to 15. is
okay and then below 20 is like
you wouldn't agree with it but you'd
accept it because I've come to realize
having done numbers myself
[Music]
so many people lie that is is yeah and
especially I've got one thing I've come
to the realization as well is that cool
say at one point I was chopping out and
going through but the reality is
is these same women were probably
getting chopped out by guys like me who
were just time wasters so probably from
what I'm attracted to is like Echo
Chambers like I could go to for that
nerdy girl who plays chess and her body
counts probably below three but then
like if I tried to put my thumb in a bum
she might be like whoa what's going on
so what's that Jesus
or she might not glasses
[Laughter]